I think we all went to Arlington for a
reason and I kind of like feel like she
is being really fake right now and I'm
really mad about it I mean I think if
Kristen's up with Brett she's gonna
leave him he deserves to know that like
she doesn't want to live there and she's
freaking just lying to his face I really
like protective of you because I really
like you and I want you to end up with
someone who like wants your life
so rip she like walks into me and
Kaitlyn and she's like oh my god I could
never live here
I can't leave us what you just had the
biggest smile on your face I've ever
seen and she's like no there's no way
like this is not the place for me and I
can't even picture it at all so then
next step we thought like we would come
home and she would be like telling
people that and we sit down and Jade's
like so what did you guys think and
she's like oh my god I loved it so much
and it made me so mad and like freaking
out for you because I know how much you
like her and I'm so scared that she is
not giving you the real Brit and it's
freaking me out
like be careful Chris thank you that was
kind of a bomb that Carly just dropped
I'm gonna ask her about Arlington again
and if she's lying I would be absolutely
crushed The Bachelor tonight event
starts Sunday on ABC